(Forrest)
There is a genuine little person
who works in my office building.
I took in every aspect
of his stature.
- Can I help you?
- No.
(Forrest)
I've never considered
what it would be like
to live in a world
where everything is designed
for people much bigger
than you.
But I was about to find out.
- Hey, Mr. MacNeil.
- Hi.
Your giant ruler arrived.
Oh. Well, no.
Now, Josh, that's a normal-sized
ruler, one foot long.
But it's--it's so big.
No, it's normal-sized.
I'm small.
Oh.
Yes.
(Forrest)
From the beginning,
I found it to be
strangely disorienting.
Even everyday tasks
became more difficult.
Oh, Ah! Ah!
(Forrest)
And the people in my life,
even my loved ones,
discriminated against me
constantly.
Forrest,
what are you doing?
I'm brushing my teeth.
Or am I too small for that?
No.
You're not small at all.
(Forrest)
Though I hated to admit it,
my father was right.
I had not fully committed
to this review.
I was not small at all.
Hey, Mr. MacNeil.
I got your normal-sized
breakfast.
That is not
a normal-sized breakfast.
That's a gigantic breakfast.
Get rid of it, please.
And we're getting rid of
all the other nonsense upstairs.
And come on off those stilts.
It's time to get serious.
Okay, sorry.
You might want
to watch your head there.
(Josh)
It's kind of a bummer, 'cause,
like, I just got used to these.
(Forrest)
Mm-hmm.
I'd found a VHS tape
in my dad's video collection
of a charming little man
named Dorf on Golf.
He is played
by the actor Tim Conway
and bears an amusing resemblance
to Hitler.
A new plan was born.
Passing through the world
of the normals,
I was subjected
to constant discrimination
and blatant rudeness.
[scoffs]
Hey, hey.
I'm crossing here.
[horn honks]
- Move it, jerk-off.
- What's the matter?
- Get out of the road.
It takes the time it takes
to walk across the street.
[horn honks]
(Forrest)
Sadly, I found even those
from my own community
didn't accept me,
so deep was their self-loathing.
Can I help you?
No.